president trump and the first lady in
quarantine after testing positive for
coven 19. now the news upending
an already chaotic campaign season with
the election just 32
days away the president and first lady
experiencing
mild symptoms but they are said to be in
good spirits the white house doctor just
released in a statement
on their condition so we want to go to
john roberts he's at the white house for
with more on all of that hey john dana
good afternoon to yes the president's
physician dr
sean connelly releasing the statement
just a short time ago
giving us an update of what the
president's situation here
uh is let's say put it up on the screen
so you can follow along here
dr connolly writing following pcr
confirmation
of the president's diagnosis and this is
the test that where they stick that swab
way way way up your nose
as a precautionary measure he received a
single 8 gram dose
of regeneron's polyclonal antibodies
this is an experimental drug that has
not yet received
fda approval they're just finishing up
phase three trials
the president has been taking zinc
vitamin d which boosts his
immune system famotidine which is a
generic form of pepcid
melatonin to help him sleep at a daily
aspirin as of this afternoon
the president remains fatigued but in
good spirits he's being evaluated by a
team of experts today will be
together rather we'll be making
recommendations to the president and
first lady in regards to next
best steps nothing in there you'll
notice about taking hydroxychloroquine
as the president did
preventively back in may along with
azithromycin
and zinc in terms of the timeline we
know that the president was with hope
hicks close advisor of his on several
recent campaign events including
one to minnesota on wednesday where miss
hicks became
ill and was actually isolated aboard air
force one on the way back
the president testing positive for
coronavirus later on thursday
hope hicks had tested positive earlier
in the day but the president's still
taking a trip to bedminster new jersey
here's what
mark meadows the chief of staff said
about the timing of all of that
in terms of hope hope hicks we
discovered that
right as the
marine one was taking off yesterday we
actually
pulled some of the people that had been
traveling in close contact
the reason why it was reported out and
just frankly is that we had already
started the contact tracing just prior
to that
event and dana we were talking about
this earlier in the day it's kind of
puzzling that the president knowing he
had exposure close exposure
to someone who had just tested positive
for coronavirus would have taken that
trip it was a fundraising roundtable
to his golf resort in bedminster asked
about that here's what kaylee macanandy
said earlier today
it was deemed safe for the president to
go he's socially distanced it was an
outdoor event and it was deemed safe
by white house operations who exactly
assessed that it was
safe for the president even though he
knew he had exposure to travel to new
jersey he was in marine one small space
air force blonde and that fundraiser
white house operations made the
assessment it was safe for the president
in consultation with others
now we are waiting for those next steps
as dr sean connelly put it we don't know
what those are we're told that the
president
is still suffering from mild symptoms
but as you know dana
things can go downhill you know very
very quickly for for
anybody and the president is in that
risk area he's
73 74 years old he's a little bit
overweight
so uh you know as a precaution i'm sure
that they are watching him closely
we'll stand by and we'll give you any
update on developments as they occur
all right please do thank you john so
joe biden is campaigning in michigan
today
after testing negative for the virus
this morning the former vice president
reacting to the latest developments just
a few minutes ago
sending my prayers for the health and
safety of the first lady and president
of
president united states after they
tested positive for covet 19.
we can save 100 000
lives in the next 100 days according to
the head of the cdc
if everyone wears a mask in public
okay so we're going to take it around
the table here um
you know it's it was shocking news degan
um
and we hope that he recovers very
quickly sounds like they're all on top
of it over at the white house
and i think about all the american
people clearly the country
as a whole has a tough road to hoe with
the virus
and the economy those two inextricably
linked so i always think about
what can we do and what this country
needs now
financially is help from congress yes
and nancy pelosi is dragging her fancy
feed on getting that out to people we've
recovered 52 percent of the jobs that
were lost in march and april
but the jobs recovery is slowing incomes
are falling
permanent job losses are rising and
literally
it is a matter of 1.6 trillion dollars
versus nancy pelosi's 2.2
trillion dollars and it it money will go
out to people who are unemployed frankly
the democrats filibustered
the deal that was in front of the senate
it was going to be help for the
unemployed for
children in schools and for small
businesses
where are they are they looking at this
situation as an opportunity for them to
wait until after the election
to gain more power rather than doing
what is right
for americans well i think that there it
looks like there had been some forward
movement
um to get that bill done and i think if
they get it to the president he will
sign it and i think that would be a
really good thing and it includes money
for testing for schools
as well um as some businesses greg any
uh
thoughts i feel like i should just open
it up to whatever you're feeling
it is it can 2020
get any more 2020. i feel like there's a
bar somewhere and
1349 a.d is sitting on a bar stool and
just bragging about how
you know the plague wiped out half of
europe european politician
and there's this other year 2020 sitting
in the corner
saying oh yeah hold my beer you know
because
it is like i this is more than an
october
surprise it's like an october asteroid
hit
um and it's another first that we're all
experi
experiencing together uh in a year first
we've experienced essentially a pandemic
together and there's
times when we come together whether it's
hurricanes or pandemics or
terror terror things like 911 the only
thing that wedges us apart
is politics and i and social media and
media these variables
tend to get us to quarrel and i i'm
trying to stay off social media
and stay and limit my intake of uh
of media in general because i just want
to think about us as americans as not as
left or right
my question is is what happens to us if
we don't hear from trump for a few days
because will we get the shakes
right it's like if the me if we don't if
the media doesn't get their morning cup
of trump
you know we're gonna really start
missing him we're gonna you know we kind
of got used to having the big guy around
and and you know it's like you got like
five you get five or six tweets a day
the producers like it we get to put it
and put it into segments
we're gonna be really really hungry for
him when he gets well i think that we're
gonna get
i'm hoping that we get some some tweets
i never wanted tweets so much
in my life um juan there's um
you know we it feels like a month ago
that we were in cleveland it was only
uh two days ago and on the day
afterwards that's when all of this uh
unfolded
well in fact that now is a point of
controversy you know
what happened in cleveland uh the
failure to wear masks
especially among the trump family but
you know i think we all should say we
wish them a speedy recovery right off
the bat
it's not easy and from what we hear he
has a fever
a little fever he has a cough some
congestion and the fatigue that you've
heard
referred to so i mean it's going to be a
it's going to be a struggle for him
and you just hope that you know he's got
the best protection in terms of the best
medical
facilities the best medical care all
that's good
but to me it's a reminder that anyone
can get sick if the president
can get sick and when you think about
that to my mind you know it's not only
that he has the best medical
care available it's also he has health
insurance right he's not going to
get into trouble because then a insurer
is going to say oh yeah you have a
pre-existing condition you had kovitz
that's not going to happen for him and
so we have to think about you know how
we as a country can come together
uh to defeat this virus because it is
not only
an illness that threatens us all but of
course it's having this terrible impact
on our economy
and we can see it's ongoing i mean it's
just it hasn't stopped and in fact now
we have more states
with rising rates of infection so to me
we got to figure out a way to crush this
virus and for that we need national
leadership i think
everybody's got to take this more
seriously stop with the politics for a
second
uh just in the way that we want him to
get well i think we got to say we got to
get well as a country
and um you know it's not just some of
the states but you see europe of which
we lagged jesse just like
two or three months behind all of their
rates are going up too so we have some
time to
think about things either you know
getting that bill passed and remembering
all the things that
work the social distancing hand washing
and masks when you need it
yeah i also with juan would like to wish
the president and the first lady a
full recovery and i think they will
recover
i know he is 74 years old and that's a
very high risk situation i think
95 percent of people at that age do
recover so we wish him well i think so
far the white house has done
a good job explaining that the
government is still functioning he's
still in command
from the residents the defense
department treasury secretary of state
have all talked to our allies
and calm the capital markets to say this
thing is going to get better and we are
fully in charge the chinese communist
party newspaper came
out mocked the president that's not a
good idea
a big pay a very big price for that the
president still
can campaign digitally from the white
house no one does a better job than the
trump campaign with that
so you're going to see his surrogates
out there as well but this is a big test
i mean i'm not going to sugarcoat this
this is you know we had
the axis hollywood situation we've had
impeachment we've had racial unrest the
president has to meet this thing head-on
he needs to confront it he needs to get
over it and i think he will